J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: So the
second part of the last
lecture introduced the idea of
alkenes, and we were talking
about the stability of
alkenes, cis versus trans, and
the effect of substitution.
We'll go on with that today, and
then go on to addition
mechanisms, which is a
characteristic
reactivity of alkenes.
So if we look at the stabilities
of these C6 alkene
isomers that we talked about
last time, we showed how you
can get the numbers for those
from the NIST website.
It's also possible to get them
from this book by Pedley.
That's the one that Professor
Wiberg, who's a big expert on
this, recommended to me as a
good source.
So here's the heat of formation
of the straight
chain with a double bond in the
number one position.
What does heat of formation,
what's that the
heat relative to?
The energy of this molecule
compared to what?
The heat of formation.
Rehearse from last semester.
Mary?
STUDENT: Is it the heat of
atomization to--
PROFESSOR: It's not the heat of
atomization.
How do you measure such things?
How do you measure the heat of a
molecule?
STUDENT: You have to heat it
up--
PROFESSOR: Can't hear too well.
STUDENT: You have to heat it up
until it's
really, really hot.
PROFESSOR: That was the way that
you got the heat of
formation of carbon atoms from
graphite, remember?
But that only needed to be done
once, to get where carbon
atom is relative to graphite.
Then you need to know the energy
of molecules relative
to graphite.
How do you do that?
STUDENT: You want to break the
bonds in graphite and then
break the bonds--
PROFESSOR: But that's a very
difficult thing to do, to
break the bonds in graphite.
Matt, do you have an idea?
STUDENT: Do you combust
graphite?
PROFESSOR: You burn them.
You compare them to CO2.
So you take your molecule and
burn it, we talked about this
last semester.
You burn graphite.
You also burn H2, so you can get
a hydrocarbon.
What's the energy of your
compound, compared to the
amount of energy that was in
hydrogen
and carbon of graphite.
So anyhow, the heat of formation
is -10 or a little
bit more kilocalories per mole.
That means it's that much more
stable than the elements would
be in their defined standard
state.
Now if you look at it for the
cis-3-hexene, the double bond
beginning on the third carbon,
it's a little bit more stable.
And that doesn't surprise you,
because we've talked about
having more carbons as opposed
to hydrogens on a double-
bonded carbon
makes the compound more stable.
That is, that the CH bonds don't
profit as much from the
change in hybridization as C-C
bonds seem to do.
Now if you have the trans
isomer, it's still more stable
by about one and a half
kilocalories.
I don't know whether you had a
chance to look at
the problems yet.
Probably not.
They were for Wednesday.
Just look at the generalities.
But you find that the trans
isomer is about one and a half
kilocalories more stable than
the cis.
Can you think of any explanation
for that?
Amy?
STUDENT: Less repulsion from
the-- in cis there's repulsion
from the hydrogens that are on
the same side.
PROFESSOR: The groups run into
one another, it's a steric
effect when they're cis.
That's worth about one and a
half kilocalories per mole.
OK, now if you make three
carbon-carbon bonds from the
double bond--
incidentally there's a table
that has those in it too in
the Jones book.
If you put three carbons on the
double bond, then it's
more stable still.
And obviously if you put four,
it's a little
bit more stable still.
Now if we come back and look at
correcting for strain,
which was what we attributed the
difference between cis and
trans to, we find that there's
3.6 kilocalories of molecular
mechanics strain in the cis, and
2.5 in the trans.
So it's what you said, Amy, that
the molecular mechanics
explains it, in terms of a
steric effect.
So the average then, for those
two, is about there.
And now if we make strain
corrections for the other
molecules as well, calculate the
strain by molecular
mechanics, there's 2.8
kilocalories of strain
calculated there, 2.6 and 7.7 in
the one that has four
carbons on the double bond.
And now you notice something
interesting about the trend.
Once you've corrected for
strain, what do you notice?
It's almost exactly linear
according to the
number of C-C bonds.
So you gain in stability, about
two and a half
kilocalories per mole every time
you substitute a C-H with
a C-C, keeping the same number
of carbons and hydrogens in
the molecule, discussing isomers
of one another.
Because of course it makes no
sense to compare heats of
formation of molecules that are
not
isomers of one another.
You're comparing apples with
oranges.
So that could be due to this
hybridization.
It could, in part, be due to
hyperconjugation, that we
talked about before, and we'll
talk a little bit
more about it later.
Now let's think about the
thermochemistry involved in
alkene/HCl reactions.
So here's HCl plus an alkene, to
give the addition product,
where H is added to one carbon,
and Cl to the other.
So notice we've converted a
single bond and a double bond
on the left into three single
bonds on the right.
Is that likely to be favorable
or unfavorable?
What's the energy of a double
bond compared
to two single bonds?
That's what we've done here.
You remember from our table we
looked at in the first semester?
Is the second bond of a double
bond worth
as much as the first?
More?
Less?
STUDENT: Less.
PROFESSOR: It's worth less.
So if we look back at that table
that we looked at last
semester and put actual numbers
to these bonds that
we've drawn here, we see that
the hydrogen chloride bond is
worth 103 kilocalories per mole.
The double bond, carbon-carbon
double bond, is a 146.
So there's 249 that we're losing
in
the starting material.
So how much do we gain in the
product making the three
single bonds?
So there's 104, and 83, and 81.
So 268.
In other words, it's profitable
by 19 kilocalories
per mole to do this addition.
And we talked about this before,
when we were talking
about chain reaction addition of
HCl, or HBr,
of HI, and so on.
All of them were exothermic by
about that much.
So it's favorable by about 19
kilocalories per mole.
Now we could also look more
specifically at these
compounds by using that data
that's in the table that we
accessed last time from National
Institute of Science
and Technology [correction:
National Institute of
Standards and Technology], to
look at the actual heats of
formation of these particular
molecules in the gas phase.
That is, before we were just
looking at average bond
energies to get an order of
magnitude idea of what's going
on, or better than an order of
magnitude.
But these now will give us the
precise values.
And where we said it was 19
before, now we see that, for
this specific set of compounds,
it's 14.5.
But we were about right.
It was a good guess before.
So this reaction should go to
the right.
But we've already talked about a
reaction
that goes to the left.
What reaction would that be, the
one that starts on the
right and goes to the left?
That's the elimination reaction.
An E2 reaction goes from right
to left.
What's the difference?
If this equilibrium lies to the
right, how could we have
spent all this time in the last
quarter of the course
talking about reactions going
the other way?
Isn't that uphill in energy?
What reagent do you use to do
the elimination?
STUDENT: Base.
PROFESSOR: Strong base, right?
Like hydroxide.
So let's see what happens if we
put hydroxide into the mix.
So in acid we get addition.
And it's favorable by 14
kilocalories per mole, in this
particular case.
But if we put hydroxide in
there, now what
will it react with?
Well, we talked about how it
pulls off the proton at the
same time chloride leaves in the
E2 reaction.
But if all we're doing is
studying thermochemistry, we
could look at where it is in the
product, in the balance of
the two sides of the equation.
So what it does on the left is
take the proton away from HCl,
to give water and chloride.
Now HCl is a much stronger acid
than water is.
So that's a very favorable
process, to take the proton
away from HCl, and to put it on
hydroxide.
And in fact, we could find out
how different it is by looking
up in that same table the proton
affinities of OH minus
and chloride, and we find they
differ by 19
kilocalories per mole.
So adding hydroxide stabilizes
the left side of this equation
by 19 kilocalories per mole, and
now it's favorable to go
the other way by four and a half
kilocalories per mole.
So in base, you do elimination.
You go the other way.
Now are these really the reverse
of one another?
Do we just run the machine
backwards to get elimination,
or to get addition, as compared
to the elimination we
talked about before?
Or is it a different mechanism
because the
conditions are different?
The elimination was done in the
presence of strong base.
The addition is done in the
presence of acid.
So you might not be able to run
the machine backwards.
So incidentally, here's a
problem for you to look at for
Wednesday too.
Use the pKa values for HCl and
H2O to estimate--
here I looked it up, actually,
the proton affinities in NIST,
and got 19 kilocalories per
mole.
But you could have done the same
thing out of your head,
or out of a simple table.
Does anybody remember what the
pKa of HCl is?
STUDENT: Maybe nine?
PROFESSOR: The exam was Friday,
I realize that.
You can scrub that now.
Anybody remember about what it
is?
I think it's minus eight.
Isn't it? [correction: -3]
How about the pKa of water?
STUDENT: Negative 16.
PROFESSOR: Right, negative 16
[correction: positive 16].
So from that difference, you can
calculate what the energy
of that reaction would be.
So try it from that difference
and see if you can do it.
That's a good exercise for you.
But at any rate, we have the
question of the addition of
the mechanism.
Is it the reverse of the E2 or
E1 mechanism?
So we're going to talk about
addition to alkenes, and we've
already done that to a certain
extent.
We talked about the SOMO
mechanism, the free radical
chain addition of HBr, and you
remember what that is, that
the bromine atom adds to give
the more stable radical, which
then attacks HBr, taking off the
hydrogen
atom, to give the product.
It gives that product, and
there's a reference in the
textbook, it gives that product,
not the one above.
And it doesn't give that one.
It's regioselective.
And remember we called this
anti-Markovnikov. Markovnikov
had the idea, as we talked about
last time, that the
carbon that has more
substituents gets more.
So if you had two methyl groups
already on one of the
double-bonded carbons, it would
be the one that gets the
bromine, that the hydrogen goes
to the other one.
But this is anti-Markovnikov, it
does the opposite.
So we've already talked about
that.
And the key feature in the
regioselection is getting the
more stable carbon radical.
But it's also conceivable that
there could be a HOMO-LUMO
mechanism, a concerted one,
where the new group comes up
to the double bond, and the
partners just
exchange like this.
Suppose you had H2 to react
with, with the carbon-carbon
double bond, a very exothermic
reaction.
So you could just shift electron
pairs like that, and
perform the addition.
Now let's look at the orbitals
that would
be involved in that.
What's the HOMO of the C-C
double bond?
Ellen?
STUDENT: Pi?
PROFESSOR: Pi.
And the LUMO is pi-star.
So let's try to bring the LUMO
and the HOMO of
the H2 down on top.
Look good to mix HOMO and LUMO?
What do you call that situation?
Rahul?
STUDENT: It's out of phase?
PROFESSOR: They're out of phase.
In fact, there's a specific word
to talk about things that
don't overlap for this symmetry
kind of reason.
Remember what it is?
They're orthogonal, Anurag says.
So there's no mixing of HOMO of
one with LUMO of the other.
Of course you could shift them
so that they mix.
But then there's nothing to be
gained, because on the left,
you're mixing filled with
filled.
That's repulsive.
And on the right, the orbitals
are empty.
There's nothing that has
whatever energies are
available for those orbitals.
So you can't do this reaction.
You can't just bring AB single
bond down on top of a double
bond and change partners,
because the symmetry is wrong
of the orbitals.
They won't mix that way.
You can't draw those two arrows.
However, it turns out that if
you use certain catalysts, in
particular metals like platinum,
they make it
possible to do this, because the
platinum gets involved.
It gets its orbitals involved,
and there can
be favorable overlap.
And we'll be talking about that
pretty soon.
You see it in the Jones book:
it's in chapter 10.
So that would be a concerted
reaction, where you make and
break bonds at the same time.
But it's also possible to do it
stepwise.
That's why the reactions are
called electrophilic, because
you have an acid, for example
HBr, and the HOMO attacks the
sigma-star LUMO, attacks the
proton to give off bromide.
And then the bromide can attack
the
intermediate cation.
So it's a two step reaction.
So the initial reaction is the
reaction of an electrophile,
something that wants the
electrons.
A low LUMO, the sigma-star of
HBr is the reagent that reacts
with the double bond.
And notice that that one works
for any hydrogen halide.
Remember all the hydrogen
halides were exothermic for
their addition to the double
bond.
But only HBr would work by the
top mechanism here, the SOMO,
because both steps were
exothermic to compete with
termination.
Whereas any of the hydrogen
halides will do this stepwise
electrophilic reaction.
And notice, in this case, that
it does follow
Markovnikov's rule.
It's not that one.
It's the Markovnikov, where
bromide goes to the more
substituted carbon, and it goes
there because that carbon
is more stable in the inter...
that carbon cation is more
stable as an intermediate.
So that's stuff that mostly
we've mentioned before.
Now let's think about the
orbitals and where they should
get attacked.
So here's ethylene, an alkene,
and we can look at the surface
potential to see the energy of
a proton on the van der Waals
surface.
So a proton likes to be up above
where the double bond
is, and it doesn't like to be
around where
the hydrogens are.
So this electrostatic feature of
the surface of the molecule
is important in positioning the
fragments before they
begin to react.
But new bonding requires mixing
orbitals, not just
positioning things
electrostatically.
So we should look at the HOMO
and the LUMO.
So the LUMO is this pi-star
orbital and the
HOMO is the pi orbital.
So the addition, as we've said,
to alkenes is
electrophilic, it goes after the
pi
electrons, the high HOMO.
So the proton, with its low
vacant orbital,
electrostatically likes to be up
on top.
That's the best place to be, if
you're on the surface of
the molecule.
And when it's there, it can
overlap with this pi orbital.
So in the various textbooks you
have, you could read about
this electrophilic addition to
alkenes.
I guarantee you there are all
these sections in there.
One about hydrogen halide
addition by R+, by the cation
intermediate, what we just
talked about on
the previous slide.
There'll be discussion of the
regiochemistry, which end of
the H+ adds to, to give the more
stable cation
intermediate.
And there'll be discussion of
hydration, where instead of
the X minus being the thing that
adds to the H+, [correction: C+]
it's the solvent water, the
unshared pair on oxygen can
attack the cation as well, and
then lose a proton, so that it's
OH that goes on instead X minus.
So you can be reading that in
your texts.
And this, just to show an
example, is from the lecture
that I mentioned was given by
Professor Siegel last year,
where he talks about how you can
do this Markovnikov
addition, chloride going to the
more substituted, OH going
to the more substituted, Br
going to the more substituted,
when it's clean, that is when
you don't have free radical
initiators there.
So all of these form by proton
first going here to get this
more stable cation intermediate.
And in this case, with dilute
sulfuric acid, it was water
that came on to do this.
And that mechanism is shown
here.
Incidentally, on the exam,
remember the last question was
to draw a very careful curved
arrows and everything.
I put this up, in part, to give
you fellow feeling,
because we graded that very
rigorously.
When you draw a curved arrow to
denote electron pair
shifts, where do you start the
arrow?
STUDENT: Where the electrons
are.
PROFESSOR: Where the electrons
are in the starting material.
And where do you end the point
of the arrow?
STUDENT: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Where those electrons
are in the product.
Sometimes they will be on an
atom, become an anion, or
becoming an unshared pair.
Sometimes they will be between
two atoms, because you're
forming a new bond.
And if you want to be thinking
really clearly about it, you
should draw those arrows
clearly.
That's why I asked it that way
in the question.
But notice that Professor Siegel
here, in drawing some
of these arrows, drew it going
on to the hydrogen.
He drew the X minus going on to
the carbon, where I would
expect you to draw this curved
arrow ending
between X and the carbon.
And to position those two things
that are going to react
with one another in your
drawing, such that they're
close enough to one another that
it makes sense to end the
arrow between them, not to have
it off here and the arrow
terminating in space, just
because it's halfway between.
So that's a lesson that I hope
will become clear.
So this shows the case of water
intervening.
So there are sections of the
book about the addition of
hydrogen halides, about
regioselectivity, about the
intermediate cations that are
involved, about cation
stability, and about cation
rearrangements.
And I'll talk about a few of
those things here, but you can
review them in your book as
well.
First about cation stability.
I took this from the text we
used a couple of
years ago by Loudon.
So he shows primary, secondary,
and tertiary
cations, how many carbons are
substituted on them, and says
of the stability of
carbocations, that tertiary is
more stable than secondary is
more stable than primary.
This of course is the
explanation for Markovnikov
orientation.
Now we can look at the rationale
for that, rehearse
it once again.
Hyperconjugation says its better
to have a carbon on the
carboncation with its hydrogen,
or whatever else
it's bonded to, than to have
just the hydrogen.
And the reason it's better is
that there's some kind of HOMO
that's in position to have its
electrons stabilized by that
unusually low-energy LUMO, the
one associated with the
positive charge, the vacant
orbital on carbon.
And in the case of hydrogen,
there are no electrons to be
stabilized, those are orthogonal
to this But in this
case, the sigma electrons that
are in the bond, even though
they aren't particularly high,
can interact with a really
unusually low orbital, and get
some stabilization.
So we've talked about this
before, this hyperconjugation.
And it could be denoted by
writing a resonance structure,
which has a double bond between
the carbons and an H+,
or R+ if it's an R group out
there.
The other rationale for this
order of cation stability is
bond energies.
And we've talked about this
several times, changing CH to
CC bonds when you have this
especially advantageous sp
square hybridization of the
carbon.
But those are theory, and it's
different to know what the
evidence is that they actually
have that order, tertiary more
stable than primary.
So the first part is the
rationalization.
Now we have to say where do we
actually get the evidence that
their stability is that way?
And several people on the exam,
when asked for evidence,
provided theory, rationale like
this, rather than actual
numbers, where the evidence
comes from.
So to get evidence, you have to
compare something.
So you could compare products or
transition states, that is
you could look at reactivity.
If you have a very unstable
cation, you would expect it to
be more reactive.
So that would be one way that
you could do it.
Another way would be compare
with a starting alkene.
If it's easier to put a proton
on, that would indicate that
the cation you're leading to is
more stable.
The cation is uphill in energy
typically, but if it's a more
stable cation, it should be
easier to form.
So the reactions, where you
protonate the
alkene, should be easier.
Or in the reactions we were just
talking about, the SN1
substitutions, the ease of
losing the anion, in order to
generate the leaving group that
is to say, in order to
generate the carbon cation
should be easier when the
cation is more stable.
So we could do either of those.
Or we could directly compare the
cations with one another,
to see which one is more stable.
Now here's a table taken from
the textbook, which gives a
table of the heats of formation
of carbon cations in
the gas phase.
So they're very hard to make in
And it says, "secondary vinyl
cations are more stable than
primary vinyl cations."
Now what's the basis for that
here?
In the table, what's the basis
for saying that secondary
vinyl cations are more stable
than primary vinyl cations?
Well we look up there and we see
a primary vinyl cation is,
in fact, the highest energy of
any of these.
And the secondary vinyl cation
is also pretty high.
It's substituted, it's
secondary, which
should make it better.
And indeed, it is better.
So it says it's better by 54
kilocalories per
mole, in the gas phase.
Now there's a problem with using
this table in this way.
And the problem is compared to
what?
Is this really saying that a
primary vinyl cation is more
stable than a secondary vinyl
cation?
Compared to what?
These heats of formation, what
are they compared to?
So this is the energy of the
vinyl cation compared to what?
What's the heat of formation?
Helen?
STUDENT: Carbon dioxide and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's the heat of
combustion.
It could have been heat of
We would add something to these,
to get heat of
combustion.
Actually what's given is the
heat of formation.
STUDENT: Compared to the carbon
and hydrogen?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, compared to
carbon and graphite and
hydrogen and H2 gas, at standard
temperature and
pressure and so on.
That is compared to the
elements, in
their standard states.
But notice that there are
different numbers of atoms in
these things.
They're not isomers of one
another.
So it's not that you can convert
one to the other and
say that this heat difference
shown here
takes one to the other.
You're comparing apples and
oranges.
They're just not the same thing.
If you want to compare with
heats of formation, they have
to be things that are isomers of
one another, where you know
their energy relative to one
another, rather than relative
to something completely
different, different numbers
of atoms.
So this particular table doesn't
help you at all
directly in figuring out, except
that there might be
some cases here, like this one.
Notice that this is C4H9, and
this one is also C4H9.
So here's a primary and a
secondary which differ by 20
kilocalories per mole in the gas
phase.
And that really does show that
secondary is
more stable than primary.
But this table definitely
doesn't show that secondary
vinyl cations are more stable
than primary vinyl cations.
So you have to think carefully
about compared to what.
Here you're comparing to
different numbers of atoms in
their standard states, not
relative to each other, nor
relative to their respective
starting materials or
products, as we talked about
last time.
So this table, in general, is
irrelevant to the question of
cation stability in the sense
that we were talking about it
in the previous slide.
Now on the other hand, in Loudon
here, Table 4.2, gives
the heats of formation of
isomeric butyl cations.
So the same atoms, they're being
compared to the same
thing, so differences between
them now do tell us the
difference between primary,
secondary,
and tertiary cations.
They got it from the same
numbers, heats of formation.
Although, in fact, you'll find
that these numbers are
slightly different from those in
the previous table.
Neither book says what the
source of these numbers is.
These NIST values have been
pretty carefully gone through.
So if push comes to shove, I
often look at those, or ask
Professor Wiberg what the best
value is.
But here you see that the
relative energy of the
tertiary butyl cation is taken
as zero, the most stable.
And now the others are 16 or 32
or 37
kilocalories less stable.
So tertiary is more stable than
secondary is more stable
than primary.
And here are two different
primaries.
Now if we look at those two, we
see that going from primary
to secondary is a difference of
21 kilocalories per mole.
37 to 16, primary is less stable
by 21
kilocalories per mole.
Now remember that the reason for
this could be things like
hyperconjugation, or the number
of carbons bonded to
the sp squared carbon, the same
factors that we talked
about in the case of alkenes,
making more substituted
alkenes more stable.
Here more substituted cations
are more stable.
But the difference is much
bigger here.
21 kilocalories per mole versus
two and a half
kilocalories per mole, from the
slope of that plot we made
for the alkenes at the beginning
of the lecture.
So it's ever so much more
important for cations than it
is for alkenes, whatever the
factor is that's doing this.
So it could be hyperconjugation.
Would you expect that to be more
stable, more important
for the cations shown here, or
for the alkenes, where the
carbon is a carbon-carbon double
bond?
You have the same factor, that
the carbon carbon double bond
here would have a low LUMO.
This has that p orbital on
carbon.
That has a pi-star orbital, a
low LUMO, and
the same deal here.
Would you expect the effect of
that mixing, HOMO-LUMO mixing
in hyperconjugation, to be the
same as when you
have a double bond?
If one stabilization is bigger
than the other, which?
So here we have the electrons in
a sigma bond.
And here we have a vacant
orbital.
In the case of the cation, we
have just a vacant p orbital.
In the case of the double bond,
we have pi-star orbital,
plus minus.
Which one's going to give more
stabilization of these
electrons?
What determines it?
What determines how much
stabilization you get out of
mixing orbitals?
Megan?
STUDENT: Overlap?
PROFESSOR: Overlap is one thing.
So it's a p orbital on carbon in
either case here.
In one case, that p orbital is
also associated
with another p orbital.
So each of them is 1 over the
square root of 2.
So it's smaller in one case.
So there indeed would be less
overlap in the case of the
carbon-carbon double bond,
rather than just a full
fledged p orbital.
So that's one factor.
How about another factor, Megan?
STUDENT: Energy?
PROFESSOR: How about the energy
match?
STUDENT: When you have a
positive charge
it raises the energy.
PROFESSOR: Think about that
carefully.
Say it again.
STUDENT: It lowers the energy?
PROFESSOR: The positive charge
makes the energy fabulously
low for the cation.
The pi-star is low, compared to
sigma-star But it's not
really all that low, compared to
the vacant orbital.
So both on the basis of overlap,
and on the basis of
energy match, you expect a much
bigger factor for the
cation than you do for the
alkene.
And in fact, that's what you
see.
It's worth a heck of a lot more.
But the bond energy factor might
be more or less similar
between the two, because in both
cases, you're changing CH
to C-C single bonds.
But this is the one that should
make a really big
difference.
But there's another factor as
well, actually, which is that
these are measured in the gas
phase.
So we have this positively
charged
carbon in the gas phase.
We saw, when we talked about the
ionization of water, how
much effect solvation has on the
ability to form ions.
So here we're trying to form an
ion on this carbon.
Can you see another difference
among these, about
stabilization by this positive
charge, other than
hyperconjugation and bond
energy?
Nathan?
STUDENT: The top one's more
polarizable.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The other stuff in the molecule,
the other three
carbon atoms and their
hydrogens, are polarizable.
But remember, there's a very
strong distance dependence.
You have to be really close to
get a lot of
advantage out of that.
So with t-butyl, you have all
the other atoms really close
to the positive charge to be
stabilized by polarization.
Here you have that one much
further away.
Here you have two of them
significantly further away.
And here you have this one
significantly further away,
and this one off in left field.
So we can see that there's going
to be "intramolecular
solvation" you might call it,
but nobody else calls it that.
But this effect from
polarizability in the gas
phase is going to be very
important.
But if you go into solution,
it's just the reverse.
Because the primary one up here
has the positive charge
very exposed.
So neighboring molecules could
get very close to that.
So in the gas phase, it's the
atoms within the molecule that
are solvating the positive
charge, and their electrons
being stabilized.
But if you go into regular
solution, it turns around.
So these differences in the gas
phase are much bigger than
the effects that you would
actually see in a solution
reaction, where the primary
cations are more stabilized by
the surrounding molecules.
So for example, if you do SN1
reaction, t-butyl bromide is
only about 5 kilocalories per
mole easier to ionize than
isopropyl bromide.
That we saw in that--
remember where methyl, ethyl,
isopropyl t-butyl.
t-Butyl was unusually easy to
substitute,
because it went by SN1.
But if you looked at the
isopropyl, it also was going
partly by SN1.
And it turns out that it's about
5 kilocalories harder
for isopropyl.
But here the difference between
t-butyl and the
isopropyl--
the equivalent of isopropyl--
is 16 kilocalories per mole, or
even more.
So it's very strongly attenuated
in solution.
People often talk about gas
phase being intrinsic values
for things you can measure, like
the heats of formation of
these things, that that's the
ideal.
The reason it's ideal is you can
compare it with
calculation.
But it's not an ideal reference
if what you're
interested in is predicting
reactions in solution, where
that solvation is going to make
a lot of difference.
Now here's addition of HCl to an
alkene.
So is this Markovnikov or
anti-Markovnikov addition?
Natalie, do you remember what
Markovnikov and
anti-Markovnikov means?
STUDENT: Your anion goes to the
more substituted--
PROFESSOR: Does the anion, the
non-hydrogen thing, go to the
more substituted carbon in this
case?
Yeah, it did.
And why?
Of course, what we would expect
is that it would be
attacked, and this would give
the more substituted cation,
rather than attacking the
central carbon, and having the
primary cation as the
intermediate.
Then chloride goes over and
forms a new bond, and you have
the product.
So that's Markovnikov addition.
However that's only 17% of the
product.
The 83% of the product is that.
Can anybody see what's funny
about that product?
Is that the anti-Markovnikov
addition?
Natalie?
STUDENT: No, it's also just as
equally substituted--
PROFESSOR: I can't hear very
well.
STUDENT: That carbon is equally
substituted as in the
first case.
PROFESSOR: Ah, the substitution
of
the carbons is different.
What has happened?
We saw this before.
Chris?
STUDENT: A methyl shift.
PROFESSOR: A methyl has shifted.
It's rearranged.
In fact, what shifts is a methyl
group, but it's a
methyl with its electrons.
It's a methide shift when you're
talking about cations,
as you will see here.
So it's shifted a methyl across,
so what's happened is
that those electrons--it's like
hyperconjugation, that
those sigma electrons are
stabilized by the vacant
orbital on the carbon.
But they're stabilized so much
that the methyl with its
electrons, with those bonding
electrons, the
methide, shifts across.
If you want to have fun,
sometimes when you draw a
rearrangement, you draw a little
loop in the arrow,
isn't that cute?
So the methide has shifted
across to give this more
stable cation, this was
secondary, this one is
tertiary, and then that gives
83% of the product.
So what this says is that the
rearrangement, the methide
shift, competes with reaction,
with the collapse of the ions,
chloride attacking the positive
carbon.
So both things happen, and they
have similar rates.
Now suppose you had a lot of
some other nucleophile there,
like water.
Now the unshared pair of water
could fill the role that
chloride filled here, then lose
protons, so you got H2O+,
then it loses a proton.
So you can get this alcohol, or
you can get
the rearranged alcohol.
So the fact of this
rearrangement is, of course,
additional evidence that you had
the cation intermediate as
it was in SN1 reactions, where
the rearranged skeleton showed
that there'd been a cation
intermediate.
So when you do acid-catalyzed
hydration of a double bond,
adding H and OH, you have to be
aware that there's the
possibility of rearrangement.
If the skeleton is one where you
would form one cation, but
then a methide shift, or a
hydride shift, could give a
more stable one.
Now let's look at the influence
of
halogen in these cations.
So here we start with acetylene
and add HCl.
So we've started to give the
more substituted vinyl cation.
Remember the table, it said
primary vinyl cations are less
stable than secondary vinyl
cations, even though the data
was not the appropriate data to
support that, it's
absolutely true that vinyl
cations are very hard to make.
So this is not such an easy
process.
But then it can add chloride, so
you have this product,
which is the Markovnikov
product.
The proton added to the terminal
carbon to make the
more stable secondary, rather
than adding to the central
carbon to make the less stable
primary cation, so the
chloride ends up there.
And this is perfectly
reasonable.
But it went by way of this
unstable vinyl cation.
So it turns out that this
addition, this kind of
electrophilic addition to
alkenes, is 100 to 1,000 times
slower than it--
to alkynes is 100 to 1,000 times
slower than to alkenes.
It's much harder to add to
triple bonds than to double
bonds, because you get these
unfavorable vinyl cation
intermediates.
Well fine.
But now we have a double bond.
We have Markovnikov
regiochemistry, but if you
have excess HCl, you can add it
again, and get a second
Markovnikov addition.
Now suppose you didn't have an
excess of HCl.
Suppose you just had one
equivalent of HCl.
What product would you expect to
get?
Jack?
STUDENT: Still that.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: Why still that?
STUDENT: Because the double bond
is easier to attack.
PROFESSOR: Ah! The double bond
is easier to attack than the
triple bond.
So if you didn't have enough
HCl, still this would be much
more reactive than this.
After you form any of that, it
will be reacting 100 to 1,000
times faster per molecule than
that did.
So you're still going to get
this product.
Jack's right.
Under certain conditions, these
are the yield you got.
It was 56% and 44%.
I suspect that if the reaction
had been carried on longer,
you would do what Jack did, well
you'd
go all the way there.
But under certain conditions at
least, the reaction was
interrupted, and that was the
product distribution.
Now it went obviously by way of
this cation intermediate,
the second step, protonated to
give this substituted cation.
Now we have a question: is the
halogen, as a substituent,
favorable or unfavorable for
purposes
of forming the cation?
Jack help us out here.
Was this second step what you
expected to
be in terms of rate?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: Is it unusually fast
or unusually slow
compared to what you expected?
STUDENT: Slow?
PROFESSOR: Fast?
Slow?
What did you say before?
This should react 100 to 1,000--
being a double bond--
should react 100 to 1,000 times
faster than this.
Did it react 100 to 1,000
faster?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
It didn't react any faster at
all, or roughly the same.
So for some reason this was
slowed down by some several
powers of 10.
What could've slowed it down?
STUDENT: The chlorine could've
stabilized the cation.
PROFESSOR: Because of the
chlorine, it could be hard to
get a cation.
Would that make sense to you?
Why?
STUDENT: Because the chlorine
has
electrons that can overlap.
PROFESSOR: The question is how
hard is it going to be to form
this cation, which we did by
putting a
proton on that carbon.
The alkene carbon gets a proton
gets that cation.
So is it harder?
Sebastian, what do you say?
What effect do you think the
chlorine had?
STUDENT: The electron induction
pulls the electron
away from--
PROFESSOR: The sigma bond is
electron withdrawing.
The electrons around the carbon
are lower in energy
because they've been sucked away
by the chloride, so it's
harder to form the cation.
That would explain why we get
this ratio here.
That this second step, even
though it's an alkene and
should be enormously faster, is
not any faster, because
this chlorine is slowing it down
by
pulling electrons away.
It can't provide electrons to
the proton.
Now Sebastian, keep going for
us.
How about the regiochemistry?
So the second step is slow,
that's what we were just
talking about.
How about the regiochemistry of
the second step?
That is, is it Markovnikov or
anti-Markovnikov?
That is, the proton could have
added here, to give this
cation, or it could have added
to the central carbon to give
the other cation.
Which did it do?
Did the new chlorine go on the
more substituted or the less
substituted?
STUDENT: On the more
substituted.
PROFESSOR: On the more
So the chlorine slows it down,
but it's still Markovnikov.
This cation is better to get
then the other cation.
STUDENT: It reacts better with
the chlorine.
PROFESSOR: Now you might say,
aha.
The choice here is between a
secondary, whatever the
chlorine is, and a primary.
And primaries are bad to get,
you don't want to protonate
the center one, because it would
be a primary cation.
But notice here with HBr, when
it's symmetrical.
Still the two bromines go to the
same place.
So that it looks like the
chlorine is welcoming the
formation of a cation.
Or at least the bromine, in this
case, is welcoming
formation of that cation, rather
than that cation in adding
the second proton.
So the answer is yes.
Is it favorable or unfavorable?
It's both.
It's hard to make the cation
because of this sigma electron
withdrawal.
But if you form the cation,
where do you want to form it?
Next to the chlorine.
Why?
Chris, do you have an idea?
If you're forced to make a
cation, say in this case when
you put that second bromine in,
you could've made the
cation either here or here.
Both of them with respect to the
carbon would be secondary,
but this one, the one you
actually form, where the
bromide comes in has a bromine
on it.
It's hard to form it because the
sigma bonds are electron
withdrawing.
But if you form it, form it next
to the bromine.
Why?
STUDENT: It's polarizable, so it
makes
it even more effective.
PROFESSOR: Polarizability is a
good point.
That wasn't what I was thinking
of,
but it's a good point.
What else?
STUDENT: Lone pairs on the
halogen.
PROFESSOR: Lone pairs on the
halogen can be stabilized by
overlapping, so you get
resonance stabilization.
So if you're going to make it,
make it where you can get help
in the pi system.
So that's really, I think,
interesting about the halogens.
That they could be deactivating,
but still want
to have the cation next to them,
because of the different
role of the sigma electrons, and
the pi electrons.
OK, thanks for sticking around
here.